[Applaudissements]
aline le nouveau film de valérie
lemercier inspiré de la vie de céline
dion fait un carton en france j'ai
tellement regardé ces lignes chanté
parlé dans tout les longs à tous les
âges que elle est rentrée sans vouloir
aux côtés de valérie lemercier dans
cette coproduction franco-canadienne des
acteurs québécois comme danielle fichaud
qui interprète la mère de la chanteuse
moi je la voulais et manque bienveillant
maman ours au coeur de ce conte de fées
l'ascension spectaculaire d'une
chanteuse aux origines modestes et une
histoire d'amour aux accents de comédie
romantique
sylvain marcel incarne l'imprésario la
diva ya trois personnes qui ont vraiment
aimé céline il ya maman dion et rené
angélil et valérie non merci je trouve
ça bien dit elle a fait quelque chose de
beau de doux de tendre il ya aucune
moquerie dans le film nous avons demandé
à des femmes de céline dion de nous
donner leurs impressions estevan
pierrick a vu 99 concert de céline dion
dans sa vie les fines et le pot
convaincu la plupart du temps son
émotion qu'elle a voulu donner un thé là
mais quand on regarde l'ensemble du film
je peux pas ne pas dire que j'aime eu
complètement même déception pour safia
le lait qui est devenue chanteuse à
cause de céline et qu'il a rencontré à
deux reprises en gros c'est comme une
chanteuse qui est amoureuse de son
gérant qui est plus vieux qui veulent
des bébés que ça marche possible ce giro
tenue du film je trouve sympa je pense
que monsieur
la chanteuse pomme crois que l'accueil
sera différent ici je pense qu'il va
être reçue complètement différemment en
france et ici parce que en france on a
beaucoup moins de détails sur sa vie
mais valérie lemercier est catégorique
cfm est une lettre d'amour moi j'ai
veillé au grain tout le temps pour qu'on
sente l'amour qui transpire de cette
famille là de ce couple là de cette
fratrie donc moi il y avait que ça qui
m'intéressait et les pièges je les ai
pas qu'ils aient pas vues elle n'a pas
rencontré la diva mais espère qu'elle
verra aline et que le film ne plaira
j'ai fait dire il depuis deux ans
qu'elle si elle veut voir le film sait
où elle veut quand elle veut et son fils
a demandé à voir le film hier en lui un
employé
allez ne prendra l'affiché au québec le
25 novembre ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal